wir waren ja jetzt mit haftbefehl in
offenbach unterwegs im rahmen des
interviews und das ist wirklich ein
phänomen man hält mir ihm an einer ampel
neben eben ein anderes auto der bot
sofort erkannt er ist tatsächlich der
populärste rapper würde ich sagen dem
momente in deutschland gibt also sowas
habe ich selten erlebt so und das hat zu
problemen geführt zu einer
beinahekatastrophe auf dem rheinkultur
festival vor kurzem und hierauf kriegs
und wird er zum ersten mal ein statement
dazu abgeben und seinen standpunkt
erklären bitteschön also
haftbefehl bei pixum ganz ganz bald aber
vorher kurzes statement man so
reinkultur das war eine ziemliche
katastrophe was ist jetzt genau passiert
was da passiert ist die polizei hat mich
nicht auftreten lassen weil dazu viele
menschen waren und wegen der laufwerk
geschichte wie jetzt vor kurzem passiert
ist ruhe in frieden best in class an
alle leute dieser gestorben sind schade
aber wegen der geschichte ist halt
richtig panik entstanden weil er zu
viele menschen waren und hier von hinten
alle gedrückt haben und dann ist immer
mehr eskaliert und die polizei hat nicht
auftreten als nur dass sie bescheid ist
also ich hab mich fresse gekriegt
weil sein internet
sagen ich hab nicht auf die fresse
gekriegt ich habe kein problem mit der
veranstaltung gehabt ich wollte
auftreten
aber ich war da aber die polizei im
stich gelassen da ist es mein statement
es tut mir leid an alle leute die fahrt
sehen wollte man alle leute die mich
sehen wollten und die an alle rapper ich
wollte mich erst mal bei den anderen
rappern entschuldigen dass sie nicht
auftreten konnten weil das passiert ist
tut mir leid im namen von meinen fans
entschuldige ich mich und an meine fans
so was soll bitte nicht mehr vorkommen
dass eine lösung man muss auch mal sagen
der punkt ist deine fans haben quasi für
die störung gesagt die haben gesagt
haftbefehlen muss kommen haftbefehl muss
aber im endeffekt wandel
überwiegend meine fenster so was ja das
war ja die mehrheit und die haben dann
die bühne bestimmt wir haben leider die
bühne gestürmt ja und
keine ahnung warum sie das gemacht haben
aber joussen jung
sehr unbedingt haben mich schon was
getrunken gehabt und haben einen über
den durst getrunken wahrscheinlich wie
ich auch gerne machen aber man sollte
sich immer kontrolliert egal was man
macht und ja es tut mir leid und das war
mein statement zur rheinkultur wir sehen
uns in steinach nächstes jahr
hoffentlich auf der rheinkultur und dann
mein gas und da fliegen keine boxen
mitte der halle bitte an den
veranstalter kein armida kein ami
live-act bitte
als letzter also wir sehen die leute
reste wachstum mutter wenn du müsstest
auf die bühne und an den richtigen
kleinstädte vielleicht sollte er den
platz größer machen damit sowas nicht
passieren wenn die techno leute 30.000
leute reinpassen warum sollte nur 7000
reinpassen da sollte man den platz
vielleicht ein bisschen vergrößern
ich wäre auch bereit für mich war es
kein problem wenn ihr die backstage noch
viel kleiner gemacht weil sie wirklich
war schon groß also ich hätte kein
problem damit ok ich hab keinen star
alliance so sein statement
haftbefehlen jetzt ganz bald bei clixoom
hier dranbleiben abonnieren naja kommt
guckt alle gut dadurch wirst du bist
raus und christoph ersten beiden haben
wir wissen kommt schon mal besser mal
seit august so und die mahlzeiten wir
genau hier ein pass auf ich kann sich
jeder bam jhe ist es papa ist okay okay
und das ist dein lieblings und frist
hinaus süßer gleich sehen und sagen ihr
habt gut
setzen wir das jetzt mal
ausgetragen
wird aber
das sieht nun also leute hier auch mal
wissen wollte die gemischte gruppe für
drei personen und person oder zwei
personen oder eine person da will ich
auf jeden fall zu schlagen wie gesagt
hier komme ich gerne essen komplett
straße nummer
1 kommt alles vorbei und gibt euch wir
uns die münchner gestern am tag was
sagst du zu dem der beste den ich je
getroffen habe hunger und appetit dann
lass uns mal schmecken ja